[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 15
février
l'artiste de l'ancien champion de bmx
jean-claude l'ouvrier est aussi artiste
peintre il a décidé de marier ses deux
amours dans un seul tableau en
s'inspirant de manon valentino elle
aussi championne dans la même discipline
il présente son d'avant ce moment à art
capital une grande exposition à paris le
chorégraphe ifrad ya continue son
exploration de l'identité par la danse
cette fois il s'intéresse aux danseurs
hip hop 3.0 sera présenté aux prises le
21 février prochain et on qu'on le
connaisse la mer il est maintenant
réalisateur grand corps malade de temmar
du 14 février à l'ugc skywest pour
présenter son premier film inspiré de
son expérience personnelle patients
depuis le 14 février le grand palais à
paris accueille une nouvelle édition
d'art capital
une grand rendez-vous où près de 2000
artistes qu'ils soient confirmés ou
émergents expose une de leurs oeuvres
l'un d'entre eux est yvelinois il est
même bucquoy jean-claude l'ouvrier
présente le portrait d'une championne de
bmx manon valentino
le tableau a été réalisé en deux
semaines il n'a été découvert que par
magot que lors du vernissage matière de
données dans son petit atelier à buc
jean cloud briller ex champion de bmx
nous dévoile le portrait sur lequel il a
travaillé pendant plusieurs semaines
manon valentino elle-même championne de
bmx qui a participé aux jeux olympiques
de rio l'année dernière pourquoi ma non
parce que parce que maintenant parce que
maintenant elle avait une histoire assez
sympathique
parce que l'avait pris
elle avait fait une grosse chute s'était
cassé la cheville visiblement c'était
pas sûr qu'elle a les jeux olympiques et
puis et puis bah non parce que comme ça
on me l'a proposé puis je trouvais ça
sympa
l'artiste qui revient à ses premières
amours pour le bmx est exposée au grand
palais à paris et retrouve manon
valentino en personne qui le découvrent
pour la première fois quand je les vis
aux lois et j'étais non non mais je
m'attendais pas à ce que soit ce grand
et forcément c'est vrai c'est beaucoup
d'émotion et puis je pense direct avec
eux je vais envoyer une photo ma maman
elle va trouver ça encore plus dingue
que je les ai vus quoi voilà je pense
que c'est gagné quoi et puis je suis
super heureux quoi
ouais franchement annexe un ancien du
circuit mondial bmx rencontré une
nouvelle du circuit mondial bmx mais en
course assez franchement c'est super
regard de braise cheveux domptés une
féminité très présente sur son bmx avant
un départ imminent sur la piste très ému
par son portrait manon valentino
rappelle que son sport a une image
plutôt masculine c'est ce que j'aime
c'est ce que j'aime c'est je fais en dit
toujours je fais un sport de mecs je dis
oui mais justement en dessous il ya une
guerrière et les gaillards sont des
femmes
il y en a eu beaucoup dans le temps et
nous maintenant on était guerrière avec
l'offrant à la fin de l'exposition
le tableau rejoindre à manom valentino a
bordeaux on reste à paris au grand
palais puisque l'exposition accueille un
autre artiste yvelinois d'année le
contenant et versailles et pas de
portrait pour lui mais de l'art abstrait
il travaille avec du bitume depuis 24
ans suite à un avc il par la nature est
principalement l'arbre on écoute sans
raison
un tronc down c'est à dire un chêne un
grand chêne comme moi tu veux et voilà
donc comment j'ai fait 7 c'était
toujours ah que du bitume comme
d'habitude 1 parce que j'ai pas mille
façons j'avais intention de faire un
arbre mais au départ comme je lui dis
dans un j'ai fait un premier geste est
très important
donc je jettent à l'impasse au monde et
bitumes et après je travaille c'est un
jusqu'au jour où
dans ce conte musical à un chêne donc
après j'ai travaillé dans mon salon
elles sont trois sur scène trois
danseurs hip hop qui joue avec le regard
le geste est l'attitude avec 3.0 le
chorégraphe ifrad ya s'interroge sur
l'identité sur la place de la femme dans
le hip hop
la troupe est en résidence aux prises
miles en cours jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine
le spectacle sera lui présenté le 21
février
c'est d'abord un regard celui d'une
femme déterminée
puis une démarche un mouvement avec 3.0
il fera dia s'interroge sur la place de
la femme dans la société à travers
celles qui l'ont inspiré la femme
pourquoi puisque ben en fait c'est un
hommage à un hommage aux femmes qui
m'ont accompagné qui m'ont nourri voilà
qui y ont cru
voilà un mois pour citer bon ma mère qui
voilà qui est plus et à stimuler
il ya également mes mentors donc je lis
bien mes mentors parce que quand
initialement j'ai fait mon parcours de
en tant que danseur au sein de
l'appareil ou quatre bambins et
christine coudun qui m'a donné toutes
les clés tous les outils qui marque on
soit en tant que danseur mais au moment
que cela en tant qu'individu 3.0 est le
dernier épisode d'un triptyque sur
l'identité de l'être humain
mis en scène par benjamin villemagne des
gestes simples et saccadé ifrad ias a
choisi un style épuré pas ce qui
m'importe
l'associé de poids puisque c'est il
s'agit de normaliser cette féminité et
donc ça passe par une réappropriation du
corps et donc c'est cette volonté que
que de gommer le surligner donc
voilà d'avoir une danse sensuelle
féminine
qu'ils soient ni dans l'imitation de 10
dans la frustration mais dans
l'expression de la femme complexe
infinie mythique du loch du breakdance
de la new style y fera via mail
différents courants hip hop et montre
que la femme dans la danse a toute sa
place et fera des ja partagera la soirée
du 21 février avec une chorégraphe cette
fois jeanne gallois elle aussi en
résidence au prisme
elle présente compact une réflexion
autour du duo ou comment deux personnes
ne font qu'une une seule et même contrat
contrainte le contact permanent
cette oeuvre est proposé dans le cadre
du festival au féminin pluriel mené par
le crazy le réseau créative
[Musique]
on reparle l'exposition à versailles
cette fois à propos des 20 ans de rue du
monde
la maison d'édition vie chinoise a édité
plus de 400 titres aient envie tard
réfléchir autour des enfants
pour cet anniversaire une librairie
versaillaise a souhaité rendre hommage à
ces illustrateurs emblématique avec des
techniques différentes de la gravure sur
bois de la peinture ou encore de l'encré
de chine
mais ils ont tous un point commun c'est
un monde coloré ce qui moi me touche
c'est que ce côté très engagé de leur
travail
que ce soit dans la couleur la forme ou
une petite folie par exemple je trouve
que de passé énormément de temps à
dessiner des oiseaux en costume tout ça
il ya une certaine poésie là dedans qui
me plaît beaucoup
[Musique]
pour notre coup de coeur cinéma de la
semaine la direction le gone ya celle de
trappes écouter bonjour cette semaine
c'est un énorme coup de coeur dont je
voudrais vous faire part
il s'agit de plans ses plans c'est ce
n'est pas vraiment un film c'est une
création de la compagnie déclic théâtre
troupe d'improvisation qui est un
attrape est donc cette année nous avons
choisi de travailler ensemble sur le
thème du cinéma et leur spectacle de
2017 leurs créations ça s'appelle plan c
c'est un spectacle d'improvisation sur
le thème du cinéma
et ils vont venir
avec leur équipe sur la scène du grenier
à sel et on vous a préparé quelques
surprises pour vous mettre dans
l'ambiance des films et la création des
films des clips et à 2 va créer des
films en direct avec vous et vous allez
les aider lors donné des consignes on a
besoin de vous public donc ce sera le
samedi 25 février à 20h45
il y à deux tarifs le plein tarif 7 6
euros mais si vous avez une carte bande
dessinée si vous avez une carte grain de
sel si vous êtes adhérent à déclic ces
trois euros il faut réserver
parce qu'il ya déjà plus beaucoup de
place c'est il faut réserver sur le site
www.declicfrance.com et vous retrouvez
aussi toutes les informations sur notre
site internet cinéma grenier à sel
points comme si vous voulez en savoir
plus à bientôt à voiture sur un
événement hier soir mardi 14 février à
l'ugc de saint-quentin-en-yvelines grand
corps malade venait présenter son film
patients qui raconte l'expérience d'un
jeune homme devenu tétraplégique suite à
un grave accident une histoire tirée de
l'expérience personnelle de l'artiste
il était au micro de mickael miro tous
les personnages du film ont existé
toutes les scènes je les ai vécus voilà
seulement moi je m'appelle fabien dans
la vie le personnage s'appelle ben
l'idée c'était de ça m'intéressait pas
de faire un biopic sur grand corps
malade ou sur ce qui était grand corps
malade avant de faire de la musique
donc l'idée c'était de rendre le
personnage un peu plus universel c'est
pour ça qu'il ya pas grand chose sur ma
vie privée
mises à part celles qui se passe à
l'intérieur du centre est ce pour ça que
le personnage s'appelle pas fabien mai
mais sinon bien sûr c'est s'est inspiré
de mon histoire
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous culturels à ne pas manquer et on
commence avec de la danse le corps du
ballet national de marseille sera sur la
scène du théâtre saint quentin le
mercredi 22 février les nouveau
directeur du ballet de marseille
revisite le ballet contemporain épouse
la question de l'être ensemble la place
de l'individu dans le groupe regardez
cet extrait
[Musique]
danse encore cette fois du hip hop le
théâtre de suresnes dans c'est l'espoir
et le bonheur des rencontres comme un
remède à la ségrégation raciale et à la
violence du monde
street dance club est à découvrir au
théâtre alphonse daudet de coignières le
21 février
[Musique]
ap
attendu
[Musique]
pour du théâtre la scène national de
saint quentin en yvelines propose europe
connexion il sera question de
l'ascension du burn out d'un ambitieux
assistants parlementaires européens qui
devient lobbyistes c'est du 21 au 25
février
et ça vous plonge dans les enjeux et les
perversités d'un monde globalisé
si je vous dis ce show must go and
arrest radio ga ga we are the champions
vous avez bien sûr reconnu les titres de
queen le vendredi 24 février le groupe
de rock britannique sera à l'honneur au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir et
c'est cover queen le seul tribute band
français qui interprétera les plus
grands titres du groupe mythique et
regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
les
constat
[Musique]
m
gfk
j'aime bien
c'est la fin du set 8 culture merci de
nous avoir subi on se retrouve macre du
prochain pour un nouveau magazine
[Musique]